あああこんにちははじめ社長ですという意味で動画のタイトルにもある通り
久々にあの道紅白動画ございまーす
口レッスン出口なんでちょっといいラットするかもしれないんですけどもこれを見て
イラッとしてもらっても可愛いませんいらっとしてもらってもいいんですけども同じ
ようなやマッチはしてほしくないなということでちょっと動画にさせていただいており
ますし
俺自体過ぎこれは一部の人に伝えたいと言うかも
許せないなと思ってもタイトルにもあるんですけども久々にね公共の面前であのドなっ
ちゃいましたね人を
あんなそういういいじゃないと思うよはずシャツは人に怒鳴るとかそういう印象はない
とんですけどもあれは俺はちょっとね我慢できなかったですね普通にマジで
あのあぶなが仏壇ちゃん入ったまであったうれしませんけどファイトんちょっとあの
ファイターダメですけどね愛とか日は絶対だめですけどあー進んでいく中でちょっと
いざとした菓子があるんですけどもこの話はちょっと前ですね最近これ仲間だったし
てるんですけども開かせるちょっと前じゃないかなあかの北3なにはまっておりまして
さらによくイカせていただいてるんですけどもこれはあるい
あの僕がさらにいったいいつの話でございますでもちろんさんだって結構今ルールが
厳しくて
まあこの中でさあマスク着けずにみんなで歯型出る理由山結構なリスクであると思うん
ですよだから僕も行く時ちょっと気をつけてぜひ溶け込んでるとが絶対行かないし人が
少ない時間帯あの朝とか
平日のお昼とか深夜めちゃくちゃ深夜とか結構
人が少ない時間を狙ってさらにゆっきゅりしてるんですけどもどうなサウナも交換
わかんないんですけども結構さんがしっかりしてたんラストが浴室ってマスクつけない
から結構強いんですよというのもあって結構だかしっかりしててあの
熱測ったりだとかなんかほんとこのが悪化している時はもう
県外の人はダメとかパウダーがある県にこのような管理者が少なかっ
だからなんですけども持ち込ませないように申し訳ないんですけども県外の方は控えて
ますとかそういう結構徹底されているサウナでは出来事なんですけども基本的には
めちゃくちゃしっかりしたサウナなんで誰も喋んないんですよいつもサンダーの順位と
言いますかサウナの中でしゃべるとか我慢か側笑い声は母
とかでてありえないんですよ普通の人はね
常識人だったら最近はこの中でサウナ室では海をお控えくださいって言うもう
喋っちゃダメねって言っていうことも看板にしっかり帰ってやるのに
そういう方が書いてあるのにも関わらず
こんなことが起きました vtr どうぞ
[音楽]
ん
たりするん
はぁっ
鈍感クロスかと
ブーブー year
[音楽]
ブーブー j
jr 北
完全相談いただけれ喋んないでもらっていいですか
使ってるんでーじゃあ
[拍手]
[音楽]
はい
どうでしょう
あの
ちょっとあの
俺は許せなかったなぁ
冊数間に嫌じゃないですかサウナ室って滅失なんですよね僕もさらについて調べたん
ですよいろいろ
コーン多湿コーンで湿度が高い場所だったらなんかポロナーの感染力が低下するとか
いろんな意見があるんですけれども
どっちにしろですよどっちにしろ見知ってねお店がしっかりとサウナ室では海を引く
てください喋んないでくださいって書いてあるにも関らず若者2人となにあいつらは
卒業したばっかりか羽で頭が浮かれたんか
鉱山ネタ不足よした2人ぐらいからわからんけどその2人といいとでした俺と同い年
ぐらいの男二人
この22の豪邸4人がめちゃくちゃサウナって喋ってたんですよ
他のお客さんが誰かいるにも関わらず
ん
お前ふざけんなよマジでもうなんかさーああもうなんだろ普通に嫌いそういう人たちが
どういう状況でさサウナルームに来てるってちゃんと書いてるんですよミスでいろんな
ところにさん画質では感染症予防の時に会話を控えくださいって書いてあるのに
他の皆賀サヲリとかもさあ後輩とかといいですけどさ
しゃべりたいこともたくさんあるよサウナ室
でそれで他のお客さんにイヤな思い術から喋らないし暗黙の了解でもよく行くさあなぁ
すごいみんなウィンドがいいんですよ
しゃべれない人はすごい多かったのになんか春来ないからマジで頭おかしい奴らが来て
あいつら何県内各てるのか
俺の隣にいるおじさんももう本当に何か良いやというか苦しそうな顔しててなんかもう
最悪だみたいな普通の子だった
1人で来てたんですけどもうもう何か
せっかくさあ皆でルールを守ってさあしゃべらないでさ
感染症予防をしてみないルール決めて可能な中で楽しんでサブのブチ壊すようなことを
するあの4人が俺マジ許せなくて
かーなーしてで珍しくとなっちゃいましたね結構な声量ですって言って俺が飛沫感染
飛ばせるような気持ちなんで
ただでかくて歌舞伎ながら叫んですけどもう本気の場合で
すいません感染症やもう何で喋っないの
d すかぁっていう声でマジで起こりましたっていう話ですね俺はもちろん屋でしたよ
俺はもちろんやだったんですけどもなんかこんな苦しいご時世にさん
やっとのお休みで
ここから俺の妄想の世界の話ですけどやっとこんな苦しい世の中でやっと見つけた休日
で一人ねー
ロンドラッグして
楽しみに来たパウダーでそんなみんなの-1た純正てそのしれないっていうのがずっと
許せなくて
俺でいいですよの後輩とかできてるからただ一人で来て何かお仕事を頑張ってるおじ
さんの
楽しいい日がファー
そんな人みたいねすら失せで台無しにされるのがホント許せなくて
俺のためというかなんか前ないからためにちょっととなっちゃったっけ
[音楽]
頭おかしんせーのマジで普通に感染後院たくさんの行くなって話も分かるんですけども
それでもルールを守ってみんなで風にをすれば楽しめる戻ってズってあると思うんで
何くそだけでそういった楽しみようなが一部いますさあそれクソ野郎どもが
個人的な楽しみのせいでみんなの安全性とか心から楽しめるものを台無しにされるって
行為が許せなかった住め俺は二度とサウナに入った少ない民度が下がるはサブナード
て言いませんなんだよサブ何知らない人から見るとわけわかんない感じだと思うんです
けど
簡単に言うと
お話ししちゃダメだよっていう部屋の中でベシャベシャくださベッテル糞野郎どもが
いたっていう話です怒鳴っちゃったすすめさすがに俺は大変かった裾の同じ
同じね室にいたので嫌だっていうのはあったんですけどこの苦しいさあ社会でさあ一人
でサブ並木って休日を楽しんでるおじさん達の木物を考えると
me
そんなひどいことはして欲しい狙って
怒ってちょっとマジでブツ切れちゃいましたねメンダーを感受性豊かなのかねそれおじ
さん普通にいつも着てる人たかったらめっちゃパパっぽいんですけどばそれでの距離は
もちろん話せるんですけども
2m 間隔とか距離はしっかり保っているもののタウンルームといえば密室だからそう
いう場所では絶対離さない方がいいと思うんで皆でルールを守って
サウナを楽しんでほしいですねなんか俺いつも言ってるさあどれもいいですよななんか
サウナーのをさあみたいなおじいちゃんとか絶対こっちの前で喋ってはいけないみたい
なサウナの長がいるんですけどその時いなくてたまたま誰も注意する人というかその
威厳のある人がいなかったからちょっとそういう馬鹿野郎共がいたのかなって思います
ねあの部からもサウナーのし頭を下げ
を選んでくださいこんな状況でもみんなが安心して楽しめる空間づくりをご協力をお
願いします
都立が割れるには2度特訓なった
dee ます
あっはっは
[音楽]
うぉっは